All right, now that we have familiarized ourselves
with some basic object-oriented concepts,
we've gone over some other things like inheritance
and how that's utilized, as well as understanding
what Blueprint interfaces are and how
we can check to make sure that they're utilized.
We're not going to take all of that knowledge
and make a light switch with it.
Now, first things first, we are
going to be making a brand new Unreal Engine project.
And to do that, what we're going to do
is we're going to go over to the Games section
so we get access to the Games templates.
Then we're going to select the third person template.
We're going to make sure that Starter Content is enabled.
And for those of you who are not aware,
Starter Content is just a collection
of content that can be used to quickly start
prototyping things out.
We're going to give our project a name and then hit
Create.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So here is our Unreal project browser.
Let me just pull that on screen.
There we go.
And from here, we're going to go to Games.
And then we're going to select our third person.
Make sure that our Starter Content is enabled.
And we're going to give this a name of BP
underscore interactions.
And I'm going to hit Create.
And while that creates, what we're going to do next
is we're going to talk about dynamic input mapping.
Now, there are two assets that
are created and utilized with our dynamic input mapping.
The first one is the input action.
The input action is going to define the action
that the user is going to do in order for this to work.
So in our case, we're going to have an input action that
has a digital pull that is just triggered
whenever we press a button.
We're then going to go to our input mapping.
And inside of our input mapping, we
can then define the various keys or trigger or whatever
control mechanisms we want for this behavior to fire off.
So let's go ahead and pop into the editor right now.
I'm going to bring this over on the screen.
Here we go.
We're going to hit Control Space.
And if we come to our third person
and then we go down to our input, we go to our actions,
we can see here we have our input action for jump, look,
and move.
So we can either duplicate this or to create a new one,
we can simply right click.
We can go down to our input.
And we go Input Action.
So there we go.
We'll say input action underscore interact.
And let's double click on it to open it up.
We can give it a description.
We go interact with light switch, trigger when pressed.
And what we want to do here is we want this value type.
We want this to be a digital bool.
And then our triggers, we're going to go ahead
and add an element here.
And if we click on this, you can
see we have a bunch of different options here.
And we're just going to click on the pressed.
So when this is pressed, we're basically
going to send out a signal like, hey, we're pressed.
I want you to do something.
So I'm going to go ahead and save that.
We're going to close this down.
Then I hit Control-Space again.
I'm going to go back up to our input.
And we're going to grab this IMC default
because this is the default input
mappings for this project.
So if we come over here to mappings,
you can see here we have for the jump, the move,
and the look.
So what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to go to this plus right here.
And we're going to click on this.
And we're going to look for our IA interact.
Now once we've done that, the next thing
that we need to do is we need to come down here and actually
define what key or controller or button
or whatever we want for this to happen.
So we're going to come here to none.
And I'm just going to look for the E key.
And we're going to go E. There we go.
And we're going to go ahead and hit Save.
Now you don't necessarily have to do this next part.
But I'm going to come up here to my Blueprint.
And I'm going to come here to my third person character.
And we're just going to look for our.
And we want this enhanced input actions.
And I'm just going to do a print.
And if we compile this and go ahead and hit play,
we should be seeing that hello right there.
So that means that that is working.
So once we have that working, what we're going to do next
is we're going to go ahead and create our usable user
interface.